this man uh back in the uh the year of
1997.
urevar lord 1997 gave me an insane
amount of great joy
as quarterback of the university of
michigan whose full
national championship title was robbed
to give
a gold watch of a retirement present to
tom osborne
in nebraska thievery back in the day
he is brian gracie here on the rich
housing show how are you brian
rich great to be with you my friend and
you know i i'm glad you clarified that
she's been a
full national championship i try to
remind scott frost on that every time i
see him but he just doesn't buy into it
yeah you know what uh brian
just because uh osborne was leaving and
you know
i guess everyone wanted to give him a a
nice gold watch
in in the form of uh an unwarranted half
national championship
um you know i i just i guess it is what
it is
it's funny we were bringing it up the
other day and i texted woodson and uh
and hutchinson you know what you've uh
would you have beaten nebraska that year
and
they they they said how dare you even
ask the question would you beat nebraska
brian would you beat nebraska if we had
if we had the same to set up
now uh back then
we you know i talked about this with
charles and hutch and and all those guys
glenn steele
i said anywhere anytime any place
parking lot doesn't matter
didn't matter that offense was not going
to score
on michigan's defense you know we
weren't an explosive offense
but our defense was second to none that
year i don't think there was any
question
and you asked scott frost next time you
have him on you say the same thing
oh he would he would right yes
he was being truthful with you okay
what was brady like back then and what
are your conversations with him like now
when you're you're doing your job and
you're sitting down with brady and
it's a monday night game right before
the the giants and he's in the middle of
an important season for him what what's
it like when you sit down
with a guy who you knew back in the day
as tommy coming into the program yeah
you know it's it's kind of crazy rich
um by the way he's still tommy you know
he'll he'll always be tommy um but
you know talking with him we did two of
their games this year he did
um their game against the giants and and
that was the first game i had
announced of tommy's in 20 years right
because i've been
you know playing and then doing college
ball and and so i i talked to them
offline i'm like dude
i never would have imagined could you
have ever imagined that we would be
where we are doing what we're doing now
and i'm so fortunate and lucky to be on
monday night football and doing that and
and he said you know what we're so
blessed and so fortunate and so lucky
and um and i just told him i was proud
of him you know for everything that he's
done and accomplished in his in his
career and
and how much i look forward to having
the opportunity to call one of his games
and i i said you had to play you know
damn near 25 years for me to get a
chance to call one of your games but
uh it was all good and you know it was
uh it was a great
experience and and uh for for our
relationship to come as far as it has
and
for me to have that that opportunity was
great so is he comfortable yet
even now in this offense brian with
three weeks to go
um what do you think i don't i don't
think so you know i
i think rich that we've we've watched
and got grown accustomed to tom
you know being uh who he is in new
england
and and comfortable and on top of
everything and i think
you know he would tell you that uh it's
been a process in tampa
and and new pieces new players um
obviously
you know the same hurdles that
everybody's had to go through but um
and a new coach who has a different way
of of attacking offensively and
um so no i i wouldn't say that he's 100
comfortable and i i wouldn't imagine
that he would be
in his first year down there so uh how
do you think the buck season plays out
final three games they're eight and five
um
again they come out of the bye and it
still didn't look
super you know it still didn't look like
we're used to seeing brady getting
ramped up in december for a long run
it looked um it looked still a bit
ragtag
how do you think it does play out for
brady in his first
season outside of new england brian
grissom well i mean everybody looks at
the last three games and two of them
against atlanta and says oh well and
then the other one i think is detroit
and
and they're going to go three and oh to
end the season but you know atlanta
elaine is a good football team and uh
and can certainly play with tampa
um but i would expect i would expect
that that bruce arians
and and and tom get on the same page
um and run the football and i think
there's no there's no questioning that
that it has to be a balanced attack on
the offensive side for them
to have any success in in the postseason
and um
that's going to be easier said than done
because you know they they've tried to
do it in the past and ronald jones
certainly fournette um but i don't think
there's any question much like we're
seeing and i'm not equating ben
roethlisberger with tom brady but
but when you put everything on the
quarterback in the passing game
especially um at that age it's not a
great recipe
and and ben roethlisberger is finding
this out in a way that's difficult
and is ugly um and and tom understands
the balance that's needed for him to to
really execute off of play action which
is what they
need to do rather than just drop him
back they've got to have that run game
brian greasy here on the rich eisen show
from the monday night football booth
with steve levy and
louis riddick who i want to get to in a
second with you um
i just a great listen man i'm really
enjoying it as i
you know i i hit you up just it's it's
it's really a great
listen i'm enjoying it immensely and
then a game like
monday hits um you know you guys were
calling it rightfully at the time game
of the year it was phenomenal
wildly entertaining what do you take
out of the result from ravens versus
browns
brian well off the top it's it's a night
i'll never forget
um you know who have been doing that
this a long time and
and um you crave those opportunities and
um it was
it was a ton of fun uh with so much um
going back and forth and i think what
really set it apart was
obviously lamar and the drama um
but what i took away on the field and
with these two teams first and foremost
with baltimore
is lamar jackson reminded everybody who
he is
and while it hasn't been as pretty or as
as perfect this season as it was a
season ago
what i was most uh happy to see is that
lamar
uh has gone back to being instinctive
and and not
worrying about the outside opinions and
what people think he should be or he
should do or he should be in the pocket
versus outside of the pocket and be a
traditional quarterback
throw all that bs out the window and
he's gotten back in the last two games
to just being
himself and being instinctual um and
and that's an amazing lamar jackson now
i don't know that
um that that lamar jackson by himself
without receivers that are catching the
ball i'll uh
marquis brown outside the one at the end
um
and an offensive line that that can
continue to protect
and run the football consistently i
don't know how far that's going to go in
the playoffs
but it gives a a punchers chance and i
i know that to grind you up and spit you
out nature of the ravens
is very much still intact uh under john
harbaugh and if and if lamar
will continue to be instinctive uh
they're gonna be a tough out
in the playoffs and then on the other
side for the browns you know
i think baker mayfield everybody wanted
to see him follow up to stack
positive games and he did that he came
out and gave his team a chance to win he
did throw that
that interception um which you know i
tried to document
in the course of the game that he it was
a ceo's
risk reward decision he was trying to
make there and he was wrong
and that's gonna happen and that's fine
it's how you respond
and this is the first time i've really
seen baker mayfield respond to that
negative play on a big stage in a big
moment
and put his team back in position to win
and so i think kevin stefanski and baker
mayfield and that marriage is
sustainable for the browns going forward
and then
um you know i will try and
uh say this as delicately as possible
because we michigan men need to stay
above afraid but
i did spend an entire day yesterday
wondering if an mvp was defecating
during the fourth quarter
of this game um during the fourth
quarter of this game
when the words cramping came into the
booth for you to
to disseminate uh were you thinking
something else did you know what
everyone was saying
on twitter about the situation brian
walk me through
uh this tightrope act a little bit for
you yeah so it's it's kind of it's kind
of funny uh
so he everybody's on the sideline it's
cold everybody has the jackets
and the mask on so it's very hard to to
tell who is who
when they're on the sidelines so i
didn't actually know that lamar had gone
into the locker room because he came off
the field
if you remember he overthrows uh willie
snead and then he overthrows mark
andrews
uh he comes off the field and then you
know the browns come on offense and i'm
i'm in the game
so i didn't even know that he had gone
into the locker room until lisa salters
from the sideline kind of hit us
but it was probably you know the browns
had the ball they were going down the
field
um so he was probably in the locker room
for 15 minutes before i even knew
that he was gone and then and then the
first thing in my mind was
okay yeah i look down to see if trace
mcsorley's warming up
and i don't see trace mcsorley warming
up so in my mind yeah i go to oh he's
just
going you know nature calls from time to
time and
and then you know brown's drive
continues now i've got my eye
one on the field and one on the tunnel
to see if he's coming out
and and there's no lamar and i'm still
looking at trace
he's not warming up i'm saying
something's not right here
now at that moment you know you have
this a decision to make
um that's a broadcaster you're saying as
a broadcaster
that's a decision yeah you know and and
obviously
things come into your mind and you know
there i i
was glad i didn't go there let me just
put it that way
you know they're playing the browns you
[Laughter]
so i'm glad i know go there uh i'm
surprised that levy didn't go there
because you know he's a little looser
and he would he would do that i know he
could have used his sportscenter phrase
to get out of town and i mean it you
know he could have really done it
he could have really you know done the
leaves thing uh
but my gosh that's all everyone was
talking about because of the way that he
kind of waddled to the locker room and
then waved the poor
you know locker room attendant who it
was egressing as he was trying to get in
in the door and then he three minutes
after midnight
this day like overnight lamar took to
twitter to say y'all
tripping i definitely wasn't taking a
poop emoji is what he said
so it's still on his mind still on
everyone's mind
what another uh i think i'll tell you
what's crazy is
if trace mcsorley does not get hurt
i don't think that that lamar jackson
comes out of locker room
and because lamar said it after the game
he said i saw
t money go down i was like okay stop
stretching me i got to get back out
there
but if mcfully doesn't get hurt it's
fourth and five
so there's no way lamar's gonna get back
out on the field
if he hadn't gotten hurt we had a
timeout go to commercial
right time for the superman to you know
throw on the cape and
waddle out and but if if that doesn't
happen
baltimore may not get that fourth and
five you know the play comes in to
mcsorley if he's healthy and here we go
it's unbelievable the turn of events
that baltimore's entire
season was on the line and mcsorley had
to be the guy that kind of took the
fall on the sword for the superman to
come back in the game it was amazing it
was just unbelievable
drama a few more minutes left with brian
greasy here on the rich eisen show i've
got a whole bunch of things to
kind of quick hit you with in the few
minutes i have left uh with you
first things up uh is your colleague
louis riddick look uh i i know the
position in which i was put
when i heard mayok was uh being rumored
for the oakland raiders job that he
eventually took and i don't want to put
you in a boomer
cower position but there is a lot going
on being discussed that louis riddick is
in fact interviewing for jobs with the
texans and
also the lions um i'll give you the
floor on
on on seeing firsthand his knowledge and
watching him work
brian what do you think of this yeah i i
i think louis is
um i mean i think he's going to be uh a
great general manager if he has an
opportunity
um and and it looks like he is going to
have a couple of opportunities and
and um listen i i don't think it's any
secret that he's interested
um and and there's going to be a lot of
opportunities more so this year than
maybe ever
um and i think uh you know i just hung
up the phone
it was on with him uh this morning and
he let us know and i appreciate that
right you don't want to hear about these
things on
on twitter and all that but uh yeah he's
gonna have a couple of opportunities to
talk
and i think that's that's really all he
wanted and um
you know it's interesting you know our
other colleague um
and chris spielman having an opportunity
to be in the front office with the lions
so
um so that's it's great i mean i think
anytime you get high quality people
with an opportunity to to get in a front
office um
i think it's it's worth the conversation
so certainly wish him luck in those
in those interviews and we'll see what
happens brian greasy here on the show
how's your dad
how's he doing he's great thank you for
asking you know
we got him on the air last week um or at
least a reference to him we got his
teammate larry zach
how great was that how great was that i
mean do you
i mean uh do you speak to your dad after
like the steelers lose and
and and go uh honestly i just want to
pull back the curtain here does it it
means a lot i assume
that that that team is still the lone
remaining undefeated
start to finish oh my gosh you know rich
everything you hear
you know the champagne and the toast
it's all true
every single one of them and why
wouldn't you
you know like so i i was on the air when
it happened and so we were texting back
and forth and uh
i said did you pop did you pop the
champagne he's like you're damn right we
did
i love it i love it it's great it's
something to be prideful
about so i'm glad send him send him my
best will you please
i will absolutely and i guess the last
one for you is
uh who in the world is equipped to beat
the chiefs
now that we're seeing them uh first
overall in the afc
which is you know woe to the rest of the
conference if that's
the way it sticks and then who is
equipped to stop
this quarterback with uh that wide
receiver in
tyree kill and the tight end who's got
more receiving yards than
any other wide receiver in the league
how how and
any a a uh a coach who knows how to put
everybody into place
who's the team that you've seen maybe
with your own two eyes
on monday night football this year that
you think is best equipped
to stop this i don't think anybody's
going to stop them rich i mean that's
the honest answer i could i could go
back and forth you know and talk about a
couple of different teams but
it would be disrespecting what's going
on in kansas city i think they they are
the class of the league
and um and i don't think it's um any
surprise
now i i do think i go back to the bills
game uh earlier in a year
and um i think that you're gonna have to
while you can't stop them
you can certainly slow them down with a
couple of techniques right running the
football on offense and keeping the ball
away from
from mahomes that's that's number one um
but i do think that the bill's defense
is getting better
and i think that um they have enough
with tridevious white
um and some of the pass rush that
they're able to
um to use to to at least compete and
that's what you're looking for
somebody to compete now you make a
couple play here or play there
uh situationally the one thing that
we've seen from kansas city is they have
made mistakes got
behind they did that last year we saw
historic
comebacks in consecutive you know weeks
i don't think that that's a great recipe
for them to repeat this year and if
they're gonna be beat
it would be that they make those
mistakes and then
the other team is able to capitalize on
them and right now in the afc
i would say it's the buffalo bills how
about that yeah i mean alan is so good
isn't he
i mean he is really blossoming to use
the phrase
really i mean his his mentality rich and
the way that he
approaches not just his play on the
field but
the way that he impacts that team and
that franchise in that town and that
city it's a perfect match
thanks for the call uh brian just a
great uh
great listen like i said and watch with
you and levy and steve send my best to
him and
and riddick and lisa salters um the
three
you know the four of you together is
just a great watch and you know
uh i haven't spoken to lisa yet but her
um asking lamar after the game
what he had left in the tank when he
returned was just next level
fantastic that was just a great way to
ask that question
thanks richard appreciate it man i love
love catching up with you and uh
we'll have to talk michigan the next
time around do you want it brian
[Laughter]
did you notice i skipped that subject
yes i did yeah we all love michigan and
we want michigan to be back that's
that's the most important
let's do it brian we'll chat in the next
couple weeks i'd love to have a if you
will in
a an exit interview after you call your
playoff game let's do it
awesome thanks pal you guys that's brian
greasy right here on the rich eisens
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here